Speaker 1: Deb's back, and she's got a fresh cup of coffee ready to take it
Speaker 1: into the AM.
Speaker 1: In case you didn't know it, you're tuned into the Deb of Night on
Speaker 1: KTRK.
Speaker 1: I'm your lovely hostess.
Speaker 1: Feel free to fantasize about me all you want, but please don't send any
Speaker 1: more drawings.
Speaker 1: The lines are all full, so why don't I provide some release.
Speaker 1: Line three, you're speaking to me.
Speaker 2: 'Sup, Deb?
Speaker 1: And what have you been up to tonight, caller?
Speaker 1: Wink, wink.
Speaker 2: [laughing] I'm getting, uh, I messed up, Deb.
Speaker 2: Woo.
Speaker 1: What's the occasion?
Speaker 2: It's a weekday.
Speaker 1: Touché.
Speaker 2: Hey, Deb.
Speaker 1: Yes, general?
Speaker 2: Oh, bad.
Speaker 2: I had this amazing idea.
Speaker 2: I, uh, you ready for this?
Speaker 1: All night.
Speaker 2: Y- you know all those problems we've been having in the Mideast?
Speaker 1: Yes, those damn Virginians.
Speaker 2: Okay, okay.
Speaker 2: So like I figured this out, right?
Speaker 2: So if we want peace in the Mideast, think about it.
Speaker 2: What makes people peaceful?
Speaker 2: Smoking this sinsemilla.
Speaker 2: And what brings people together?
Speaker 2: Pizza.
Speaker 2: So like think on this.
Speaker 2: For like half the cost of one of those, um, blockbuster bombs, we, we
Speaker 2: could like buy enough pizza and enough herb for like everybody over there.
Speaker 2: And then like, bam, instant best buds, man.
Speaker 1: Just say no, dude.
Speaker 2: Um, and extra pepperoni.
Speaker 2: Hey, you guys take credit cards?
Speaker 1: Moving on.
Speaker 1: Line four, what's keeping you up tonight?
Speaker 3: Deb, I'm about to reveal something that, I'm putting my life on the line,
Speaker 3: but the people, the people of this city and this country and this planet,
Speaker 3: they have the right to know this.
Speaker 3: Do you understand?
Speaker 1: What's the word, Gomez?
Speaker 3: This is serious.
Speaker 3: There are a lot of organizations that would do anything in their power to
Speaker 3: keep this a secret.
Speaker 1: I don't doubt.
Speaker 3: Deb, Deb, this is really serious now.
Speaker 3: Can I finish?
Speaker 3: All right.
Speaker 3: Everyone knows they've got cameras at every stoplight so th- the government can keep
Speaker 3: tabs on our comings and goings.
Speaker 3: But did you know that they then sell access to their databases to the
Speaker 3: Illuminati, who has been using that information to compile a list of the most
Speaker 3: frequently traveled routes, and then opening new locations of their well-known chain of coffee
Speaker 3: houses in the most profitable locations?
Speaker 3: And did you also know that they use those funds to suppress fusion and
Speaker 3: solar power?
Speaker 1: It all makes sense now.
Speaker 3: Well, they, the Illuminati, control all the world's energy, and because they monitor all
Speaker 3: of our energy usage, they can tell who is not watching television and therefore
Speaker 3: know who is not receiving the subliminal messages that they send to keep the
Speaker 3: sheep putting their money in banks and away from their secret headquarters, AKA Wyoming.
Speaker 1: Amazing.
Speaker 1: Anything else that you've turned up lately?
Speaker 3: As a matter of fact, and again, I shouldn't be talking about this, but
Speaker 3: I believe it is everybody's right to know that recycling is a myth.
Speaker 3: All they do with those bottles and cans is collect DNA samples from your
Speaker 3: saliva so that they can clone you and train your clone to assassinate you
Speaker 3: and assume your identity should you go poking your nose into the whole global
Speaker 3: warming business.
Speaker 1: Thank you, Gomez.
Speaker 1: I hate to interrupt this mentally stimulating conversation, but the people who keep me
Speaker 1: chained to the console at this radio station, in my underwear no less, want
Speaker 1: you to spend money on this stuff.
Speaker 4: Last year, Democratic candidate Michael Rebens bought a sports utility vehicle.
Speaker 4: Three months later, there were two separate incidences of hit and runs by an
Speaker 4: unidentified SUV in his area.
Speaker 4: Is Democratic candidate Michael Rebens to blame?
Speaker 4: Can you afford to take that chance?
Speaker 4: Can your children?
Speaker 4: Vote Republican Senator Robert Thorn, a candidate that has never committed vehicular homicide.
Speaker 4: Democratic candidate Michael Rebens has never publicly stated his opinion on child pornography.
Speaker 4: Is it because he's hiding something?
Speaker 4: Would you want a child pornographer voting on this nation's laws?
Speaker 4: Would you trust your children's future to someone like that?
Speaker 4: Vote Republican Senator Robert Thorn, the candidate that is committed to locking up child
Speaker 4: pornographers.
Speaker 4: Democratic candidate Michael Rebens recently sued Senator Robert Thorn for accusing Rebens of being
Speaker 4: a murderous child pornographer.
Speaker 4: But Rebens had previously said he was against clogging up courts with frivolous lawsuits.
Speaker 4: Wouldn't this make him a hypocrite?
Speaker 4: Would you want a hypocrite as your next congressman?
Speaker 4: Would you want your children to become hypocrites?
Speaker 4: Vote Republican Senator Robert Thorn, a candidate not accused of being a murderous child
Speaker 4: pornographer.
Speaker 4: Preparing for a business sales pitch, but don't know how to sell your ideas?
Speaker 4: Try Virtual Meeting.
Speaker 5: So if we divert advertising away from expensive television spots and spread it around
Speaker 5: full-page ads in the leading men's magazines, we can-
Speaker 6: That's an idea, but here is what I think we should do.
Speaker 5: But I didn't finish.
Speaker 6: Yes, that's a good point, but everyone listen to my idea.
Speaker 5: But I think-
Speaker 6: That's true.
Speaker 6: However, I don't think that our target market will be willing to accept such
Speaker 6: a radical approach.
Speaker 6: Listen to what I have to say on the subject.
Speaker 6: Are you ready?
Speaker 6: Good.
Speaker 6: This is a winner.
Speaker 4: And Virtual Meeting doesn't just help with meetings.
Speaker 4: It can also prepare you for debating your ideas on the internet.
Speaker 5: So I think if the Democrats are going to have a chance at the
Speaker 5: office, they are going to have to embrace the more liberal sect of the
Speaker 5: voter block.
Speaker 6: Shut up, [beep] tard.
Speaker 5: I majored in political science.
Speaker 5: I think I know what I'm talking about here.
Speaker 6: Laughing out loud.
Speaker 6: You are so gay.
Speaker 4: Virtual Meeting, the only meeting preparation device to own.
Speaker 6: That was a good idea, which was mine originally, [beep] tard.
Speaker 1: In 1984, a generation of children were introduced to a toy that became an
Speaker 1: instant classic.
Speaker 1: 20 years later, that toy is transforming to blend into a whole new environment.
Speaker 2: Hey, Bob, right?
Speaker 2: Mind if I borrow your stapler?
Speaker 2: You want staples?
Speaker 2: Get some of these, Executron.
Speaker 2: Ah.
Speaker 1: Take control of the noble Office Bots as they wage slave their secret war
Speaker 1: against the evil Executrons.
Speaker 2: Hey, I'm gonna be here pretty late.
Speaker 2: Do you mind if I get a cup of that coffee?
Speaker 6: Craftron, transform.
Speaker 6: Coffee is for closers, Office Bot.
Speaker 1: Collect 30 different corporate robots as they battle for workplace supremacy.
Speaker 2: Look out, Optical Mouse Prime, it's Cell Owner.
Speaker 6: I've got your number, employees, and you're all getting called in this weekend.
Speaker 1: Office Bots, transform and clock in.
Speaker 6: Deformers.
Speaker 1: You live.
Speaker 1: You die.
Speaker 1: And sometimes you get brought back to life.
Speaker 1: This fall-
Speaker 2: I'm afraid I can't see too well these days.
Speaker 2: Do you think you could go to the nearest village and pick me up
Speaker 2: a loaf of bread?
Speaker 6: Bread, good.
Speaker 1: The new horror RPG from Troika Games.
Speaker 6: Bread.
Speaker 2: Oh, I can tell you where the bakery is, stranger.
Speaker 2: But before I do, would you mind picking up my little girl from the
Speaker 2: lake?
Speaker 1: You are the monster.
Speaker 1: Or are you?
Speaker 6: If you wanna enter this bakery, you'll have to defeat me and this torch.
Speaker 1: Frankenstein Breadlust, coming soon to a PC near you.
Speaker 6: Game, good